all right now the gonna my name y'all
wanna know my name for right job counted
in this fight is better alright and yeah
bye just woke up bad bad I guess and I'm
flying around I guess cuz I'm um yep I'm
riding right in the window
ah the Sun no oh yeah the [ __ ] Sun is
back to kill us that's not good
do a little pirouette to make sure we're
prepared for the Sun and I like how my
bed is stuck to the wall that's kind of
cool how to panic hello mister share how
you then get okay and we can go back or
we can keep investigating barrels yeah I
don't think I'd see you just cuz you all
right let's keep investigating again oh
well I gotta ask I got that brow is it
getting nighttime or is it morning and
that [ __ ] planet I don't get it I
guess I live in the mountains I'm a
mountaineer I like to live there with my
woman and cut wood and do manly stuff
that's inside my life my life my choices
okay don't worry about it don't worry
about it don't worry you feel awkward
now I'm sorry
so my fault alright I'm I don't know
what that was
all right we're going into this thing
over here cuz there's pretty much no
[ __ ] else where to go so I see you
later planet I was nice knowing you what
you don't talk to planets all right
collect the violent items press f to
proceed through level they are covered
in blood alright so I guess we can
collect the door no we can't shall have
a barrel sound of a good bear although
not a bad bear
what whoa dude what the [ __ ]
I don't like there
helau I this tree not in the right
direction all right
this is some blood found yep give me
that give me that give me that get a
nose job or get a job all right let's go
I guess how many items do I need to
collect oh it's gone let's go and hedge
gown Oh bad well [ __ ] me I need to
collect more than one stupid door stupid
door
all right what's going on in here what
is that what is that oh it's a head
it's [ __ ] lovely it's kind of cozy
Shh don't creep up on me don't creep up
on me it's gonna go here take an axe put
it in my underwear because everywhere
else is full can we please go in here
now
I don't like this I don't like this one
bit
she's looking at my dick that's why her
eyes are so big no one there that's cool
these guys can look at my ad all right
you like it you like what you see -
pretty all right
whoa dude I don't wanna oh come on
like I would did not look friendly but
these wallpapers are nice they're like
flowers all right classroom [ __ ] me I go
over here
I started raining that's this great
apparently oh what's going on
what ah ah but uh I see you like to draw
mr. Sher our teachers nice I'm glad for
you all right
all right then I'm sorry about that was
what am i doing in here today with
finger paint okay that's cool I'm glad
but this is not too
that is not a tip wait I don't but I
know and lick it up it been looking on
here oh my god oh my god
mega prettiest awesome that's that
finger painting that's like vaginas
fruiting period like just painting so
what I would like to call it Burnett's
okay because I'm not gay okay bedrooms
let's go to the bedroom girl cuz I rock
your world with my painted girl damn
diam diam diam diam alright which where
is he
weh-weh hello dude the [ __ ]
dafuq bro Wow
he wants to sleep with me well I guess
that's okay I mean I'm pretty cut leg
it's don't [ __ ] appear in my face or
[ __ ] me
it's not that I'm homophobic I just
don't want to [ __ ] with you all right
what are you doing
see wanking hi stop that stop it
of course well what can you do 11 your
line
that's what my mama was like that's what
she said he was like current parents and
I'm like what is mom oh well he's
[ __ ] out there
well pair to come here and say in my
life and I'm like what is moment and
then she always ate your [ __ ] K like
no mom it's not funny
and that's your [ __ ] gay pants not
true my mom is awesome she would never
call me gay all right
it's not that agenda thing wrong with
being gay it's just I don't think it's
appropriate for parents to call their
son gay all right I'm gonna stop talking
about that this corridor is way too long
I don't like this one bit uh in here
maybe poor care and high doesn't open
that's fine
it's [ __ ] fine or finebros what that
is just loud noises what the hell was
that I got a shovel [ __ ] I'm not going
anywhere else
yo shut your penis hell oh well this is
open now come on Megan Fox Megan Fox I
tell ya all right this is a grave shut
da no now bat Bad Kitty bad kid Tina
back up [ __ ] up [ __ ] shut up you don't
even have your head straight shut your
mouth nice pants where did you buy nose
and awesome oh shut up go out [ __ ] me
take me come on baby all right
ah what what's going on I slam your face
and then I cut off your nip off and then
I look around and call
that is fantastic let's go in here I
think this is chapter 4 and I have a
robot arm holy [ __ ] I have two robot
arms
I am RJ Joe oh my god this is amazing
I always wanted to be a robot this is ah
what the hell
what's going up
well I don't like it all right breasts
I'm sorry I'm gonna end it here [ __ ]
[ __ ] junkie
all right like it better to be enjoyed
helps a lot just gotta come abroad today
and part of the brittle army and CHF
child on whatever I make yeah that's how
I roll that's how I got on the ladies
[ __ ] yeah my dick is stuck in the best
bet any day now let's go grab our
dinners dan stop it I'm not your dad you
stupid [ __ ] but my kid is I don't
give a [ __ ]
touching dumb boobies touching down
boobie boobie balance oh my God look at
I [ __ ]